solve P equals 2l plus 2w for L so this
right here this is just a formula for
the perimeter of a rectangle perimeter
is equal to two times the length plus
two times the width but they just want
us to solve this equation right here
solve for L so let's do that so we have
P is equal to two times two times L plus
2 times W so we need to solve for L so
let's isolate all of the L terms on one
side and the best way we could we could
just do that by leaving it here on the
right and then getting rid of this 2w
and the best way to get rid of the 2w is
to subtract it from the right but if
you're going to subtract it from the
right you also have to subtract it from
the left if you want this equality to
hold so you have to also subtract it
from the left and so the left-hand side
becomes P minus 2w P minus 2w and the
right-hand side you get this 2w minus 2w
cancels out you just have a 2l and then
if you want to solve for L you just have
to divide both sides of this equation by
2 you just divide both sides of this
equation by 2 and we have isolated our L
we get L is equal to P minus 2w over 2
or if we wanted to write it the other
way we could write L is equal to P minus
2w over 2 and we are done